let's go back to Crime misinformation
and conspiracy theories leading into
this election because that's what this
is all about at this point that's why it
feels like things are being ramped up
like crazy uh here is New York governor
who nobody voted for Kathy hochel uh
saying that it's Republicans who are
just somehow using propaganda to make
you think you're not safe in Democratic
states
governale these are Master manipulators
they have this conspiracy going all
across America to try and convince
people that in Democratic states they're
not as safe well guess what they're also
not only election deniers they're data
deniers the data shows that shootings
and murders are down in our state by 15
percent even in New York City down 20
percent on Long Island where Lee zeldin
comes from unbelievable they lie right
to your face but again this is one where
I would say to you guys you don't always
need the stats and the polls to show
everything we can read you I mean if
we've done it a million times talking
about the crime and democrat-run cities
how about you just go to one of those
cities go to New York City as I did
about a month ago and it is not New York
City of old it is not it does not feel
safe it does not feel safe when you see
people being pushed onto Subways that
the cops know that they're not going to
be backed up so then we have all these
cops retiring and then unqualified
people that are becoming cops because
they just have to take anyone to be a
cop I mean there are huge huge problems
in democrat-run cities but she she's a
liar who is spending too much time
getting Botox and not enough time
actually trying to solve problems